Russia's 2024 budget speaks for itself
around 40% of all federal spending will
go toward defense and law enforcement
more weapons are needed for the
battlefield in Ukraine as the Kremlin is
adamant it's not winding down its
military campaign against its neighbor
factories are switching to two to three
shift working days to replenish armed
supplies this is a basically a war
budget I mean the country is fighting a
war stocks are depleted weapons and
Munitions and other supplies are being
depleted and so this there's a massive
buildup of military production and
procurement arms production can
stimulate the economy and Russia is no
exception but economists say social
programs are undefended although the
2024 budget increases spending on Health
Care education and housing the military
expenditure forces aside almost all
other priorities educ in particular and
that could lead to Russia lagging behind
other developing countries in the
future what are defense costs these are
the costs of producing tanks rockets and
other Munitions sent to the front lines
and then more often than not are turned
into a heap of Twisted Metal from the
economic point of view this is burned
cash because the final product is being
destroyed then there's the threat of a
global arms race triggered by the
conflict between Russia and Ukraine
ukine While most Arms Control agreements
between Moscow and Washington are more
dead than alive Ukraine can't win arms
race against Russia on its own but it's
going to still have different kind of
support from other Rich Nations
industrial Nations and that's not a very
good scenario because there's going to
be a cold war and arms race
internationally nearly 2 years into
Russia's special operation in Ukraine
the economy is still growing largely due
to oil revenues it's a sign of its
flexibility and durability currently the
country manages to cope inspite all the
sanctions imposed by the West the oil
price ceiling is not working the
so-called Russian State capitalism is
choosing as former British prime
minister Margaret SAA once said to put
guns before butter ulia shavala El jazer
Moscow make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from aler